[Music]
well I wish I could keep this whole twin
theme going with Naomi Watts but
unfortunately she is not a twin but the
star mama does have two adorable minimis
at home that's Naomi in the middle
twinning with her son's eight-year-old
ty and nine year old Alexander it's so
funny because that we've all got the
same haircut it's like that old ball
haircut
yeah they look they look like me but
also their dad too
even though she and Liev Schreiber's
split eight months ago they made
co-parenting work for the sake of their
kids they're very sensitive people
they're fantastic little boys and um but
definitely had times where you're like
oh I can't do this um but that's what
being a parent is you know no one's
perfect you do your best oh oh
in her new film the book of Henry Naomi
plays mom two rooms Jacob Tremblay and
Jayden Lieber her but it was co-star
Maddie Ziegler The Dance Moms star and
Sia's music video muse
that may only turn to when she needs to
score some big mom points my son does
tap-dance and he was wanting to quit and
feeling like he just didn't want to do
it anymore
and I asked her to send a message to him
so I videotaped her and she did and she
said Kai don't quit this is you've got
to give it your all and it was just
really sweet of her to do that and my
son was like ah he was brought in the
way now we all know Naomi's girl squad
includes bestie Nicole Kidman and Reese
Witherspoon but was a big little lies
the rule that got away and what does
Naomi know about a sequel definitely
they're talking about doing something
else with that grouping of people
definitely I'd love to be included I was
very sad I wasn't because it was such
good good stuff there they all did
[Music]
you